throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament that dragon
marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
as mortal kombat i've always talked
about respecting the material
and respecting the fans they all deserve
to see their beloved characters elevated
to this
cinematic height this really comes
across
as a powerful experience that we haven't
seen before
it's this grounded dramatic but violent
tale
what is so striking about molten combat
is how expensive the story
is it's epic
we have all the great characters that
the fans love
i'm sonya my name's jax that's kano
i'm lou kang
lord ryden scorpion i
am zero the interesting thing about
playing a video game character
is that you have to walk this line of
being larger than life
but also making that person real there's
actually
rich emotional life behind every single
character
we need to be authentic you need actors
who can perform the actual movements
and stunts it's mind-blowing what they
do
and i think that fight element that has
always been in the game
can be brought to life on the screen
that's not for cg i promise you
no matter how many of my people you put
in the ground
we will not fail
i've always believed that something
elegant and beautiful can cohabitate
with
brutal and primal
all of the detail gives the audience a
sense of realism and connectivity to
this world
the first time that i started seeing all
of these guys in costume i was blown
away
they've completely brought all of these
characters to life
this is more than just seeing a movie
produced this is
seeing something that i've been
passionate about my whole life finally
come to the screen
i love working on this kind of
international project
[Music]
it really represents the mortal kombat
world
i hope it's both a reward for the fans
and
a new experience
don't be fooled that it's just a game
it's more than that
it's cinematic it's beautiful there's
heart and there's emotion
all those ingredients together it should
be a fun powerful ride
so enjoy get over here
[Music]
so
[Music]
you